back at the garden where when julius
randle suits
up against the lakers there's extra
emotion mike and clyde were talking
about that and part of it is because he
reflects on the two years he spent there
with kobe bryant
it was bryant who taught him that
whenever you land in the next city for
the next game you hit the gym to put up
shots before you go to the hotel
no matter how late or how inconvenient
that may be
it's the game and it's the work that
comes first well last spring not long
after brian's passing
randall landed in detroit it was late at
night the knicks found a local high
school that agreed to stay open super
late so randall could get that work in
when he arrived the athletic director at
the high school was waiting for him and
said
it's good to see you guys don't really
show up here to do that kind of work
anymore
matter of fact the last guy to come in
and shoot late like this
it was kobe rangel said the moment gave
him chills that it was
really emotional and what he's most
proud of is that that tradition is
something that he's passed on to the
knicks so now when he's finding those
gyms late at night mike and clyde
he's not going alone he's going with his
knicks teammates
they're all doing that work and it's all
because kobe
taught him that that's what it takes